as she voted in 2020's election it would
have been hard for aung san tsuchi to
predict her greatest political success
would lead to her downfall
since last year's coup in myanmar she's
been detained in isolation only
appearing in court to face charges that
may lead to years in prison
nonetheless senior members of her party
believe she still has a major role to
play
she will have to do
more and more for democracy
and for burma
yeah i'm now
approaching 58
she's 76
but she is
much healthier than me but the events of
the past year have shown that aung san
tsuchi's policy of engaging the military
didn't work
she even went so far as to defend the
army's violent crackdown against the
rohingya that lost her many supporters
on the global stage while that didn't
punish her reputation at home it also
failed to stop the generals seizing
control
the majority of the people
understand that
you know aung san tsuji was trying
a compromise solution a compromised
approach she went as far as appeasing
the military in power
but of course that failed it's very hard
to get a sense of public opinion inside
myanmar with the military arresting
people for their political beliefs but
here in the thai border town of messor
there's a large exiled community
and a variety of opinions about the
woman simply known as the lady i want
san tsuji to be released so that things
can change
i want new people to take over these
positions because she is too old and
those people should be young like us
protesters continue to take to the
streets risking their lives to oppose
military rule and calling for a new
myanmar freed from the constraints of
the past
all of this is happening without aung
sun tsuchi
if or when she's released she may find
herself in a much diminished role tony
chang al-jazeera on the thai myanmar
border